you
hi
hello
this is working
hello
next speaker is uh sangha mitradatta
hi thank you everyone for having me here
today
so today i'm going to talk about some
strategies for fair and reliable machine
learning
that are deep rooted in causality and
information theory in particular an
emerging body of work and information
theory
that is called partial information
decomposition so machine learning is
entering into every aspect of our lives
these days
such as hiring education lending etc
so while these models are really great
at learning all kinds of patterns
present in the data
but
blindly learning all these patterns can
sometimes lead to unintended
consequences
like propagating biases and disparities
with respect to gender race age
nationality etc
that can have adverse effects on
people's lives
and in many cases is also disallowed by
law
so when it comes to identifying
addressing legal disputes or even
informing policies and interventions
only identifying the final bias in a
model is not always sufficient
we really need to dig deeper
and understand
how the disparity arose and answer
another question that bridges the fields
of fairness
explainability and law
that is how can we identify and explain
the sources of disparity in machine
learning models
so as an example
let us consider the hiring of a software
engineer for a safety critical
application
we have some inputs that go into a model
and the model decides whether to hire or
not
now it has been shown that even if these
protected attributes like gender race
age etc are not
explicitly used as input to the model
the outputs can still uh be correlated
with these protected attributes because
the other features might be strongly
correlated with these protected
attributes
so and this also closely connects with
the idea of a disparate impact
but then sometimes certain features are
very important for a particular
application
like coding test score might be really
critical in the hiring of software
engineers
and there are also similar discussions
in law which says the disparate impact
may be exempt
if it can be justified by some
occupational necessity
like coding test score may be critical
for the hiring of software engineers
our weight lifting ability might be
critical in the hiring of firefighters
but then aptitude test may not be so
critical as in this landmark court case
of griggs versus duke power
so the question that i am interested in
is
given a choice of critical features
how do we quantify if the disparities
exempt or non-exempt
and towards answering this question
our main contribution is a systematic
measure of non-exam disparity
which is the bias that is not justified
by the critical features
so this is my problem statement or
notations that i'm going to talk about
right now
z is the protected attribute which
denotes
gender rays etc
then we will have some features that go
into a model and produce the model
output y hat
now the critical features will be
denoted by xc
and all the remaining features which are
non-critical or general are denoted by
xg
and we assume that all of these features
are generated from an underlying
structural causal model or data
generation process which involves all of
these latent random variables
now the question is given a choice of
critical features xc what is a good
measure of non-exam disparity
once we have such a measure it can be
used either for auditing that is to
compute and see whether a model is
showing non-exam disparity or not
or it could also be used during training
for instance as a regularizer with the
loss function
but before we get there the first
question is how do we quantify this
quantity
so one candidate measure is conditional
mutual information or conditional
independence
that is the model will be fair if the
output y hat is entirely independent of
the protected attribute z
conditioned on the critical feature
xc but in this work we also make a key
of observation
that conditional dependence can
sometimes falsely detect bias or
misleading dependencies
even when a model is causally
fair so to understand what i mean by
this
i'll show a counter example
so let's consider a causally fair model
here we have
the critical feature coding test score
which depends on
gender or race and the true inner
ability
then we have the aptitude test score
which happens to only depend on the true
inner ability
and that the model makes its decisions
only based on this true inner ability
you which is independent of gender or
race
so such a model is causally fair from
the definitions of causal fairness that
is the output y hat should not depend or
vary with z
when you fix all the inner abilities u
but if we naively condition on a
critical feature here we will falsely
get a dependency because the conditional
dependence is greater than zero here
so one desirable property for such a
measure of non-exam disparity is that
the measure should be zero when the
model is causally fair
so in summary conditional mutual
information or conditional dependence
does not satisfy the causal fairness
property
and this limitation actually leads us to
look into this emerging body of work in
information theory
which is called partial information
decomposition
which further decomposes conditional
mutual information into two quantities
unique information and synergistic
information
and this unique information happens to
satisfy our causal fairness property and
some others
so what is this unique information
to understand this we'll look at an
example
so we consider two very similar looking
scenarios
in one case
on the left the critical feature
xc depends on z but the output doesn't
depend on z
which is the gender or race
whereas on the example on the right
the output has some information about
gender z that is not in the critical
feature xc
which is not fair
so
conditional mutual information happens
to be same for both of these examples
but a desirable property is to be able
to distinguish between these two cases
and say that in the first case there is
no disparity whereas in the second case
there is
so unique information is defined as
follows
it is the minimum conditional mutual
information
when the marginals between
z y hat and z xc are preserved
but the joint distribution of the three
variables are allowed to
vary so if you're familiar with
simpson's paradox or even interested in
mutual information unique information is
essentially the
intersectional dependence between mutual
information which is just dependence
and conditional mutual information
and this unique information will go to
zero whenever either of them goes to
zero
and this quantity satisfies our property
one as well as some other desirable
properties
but then we look into some more nuanced
examples which are again non-faithful
causal models
where even unique information alone
might not be sufficient
for instance these kinds of scenarios of
mass discrimination where the output
might be like an xor of
gender and inner ability that is
your the candidates with men with high
inner ability and women with low inner
ability are being shown an ad whereas
the other two groups of people are not
being shown an ad
so this remaining part i might go a
little bit quickly but because of this
limitation of
unique information
we finally arrive at a causal measure
that
synthesizes both partial information
decomposition and causality
and this measure satisfies some of the
properties that i already discussed
as well as some natural monotonicity
properties as well
but this measure depends on the true
structural causal model or knowledge of
the true structural causal model
but the idea is that i believe that
even if this measure depends on the
causal model we first need there is
value in first finding a measure that
satisfies all the axioms however
difficult it might be to compute
because then it can serve as a benchmark
for other observational relaxations and
help us understand their pros and cons
and also this observational unique
information is actually good enough for
a lot of situations and only for the
case of the mass discrimination is where
we need to move on from the
observational unique information to this
measure that leverages both unique
information and causality
then we also have some impossibility
results that no purely observational
measure can satisfy all the desirable
properties
but nonetheless the partial knowledge or
assumptions about the causal
relationships they can correctly
quantify non-exam disparity
and then we perform some case studies
using these observational measures on
artificial and real data as well as some
analysis on
the cmu graduate admissions data sets
now i'll very briefly touch upon two
other problems that i am also interested
in
so one of them is this question of
understanding social media and filter
bubbles like
let's
say we a person gets to see ads that
they really like
if you like to read new york times you
only get recommendations from new york
times if you like fox news you only get
recommendations from fox news
so how do we diversify recommendations
in a manner that
a person's interests are also retained
and here these kinds of
exempt and non-exempt topic bias can
play a role in understanding
how should you diversify recommendations
another question that i am also very
interested in is the quantification of
fairness and accuracy tradeoffs
so in this work i use an existing
measure of fairness that is equalized
odds and i quantify the trade-off
between accuracy and fairness using
these tools called churn of information
so in summary
this work
my work
bridges between
several fields like causality and
information theory
to arrive at measures of fairness
and in future work i'm also interested
in uh understanding
how these techniques can be
applied uh how can we arrive at better
estimators for these quantities
as well as have broader conversations
like what is the right interpretation of
laws for algorithmic hiring
for which i also believe it is essential
to collaborate with lawyers and social
scientists
so thank you so much for
having me here
[Music]